[Música]
en Los Ángeles en Estados Unidos unos
500.000 estudiantes se quedaron sin
clases debido a los tres días de
protesta decretados por los trabajadores
del sector escolar que unieron fuerzas
para reclamar mejores condiciones
salariales y culpan a los sindicatos del
estancamiento en las negociaciones
en Perú la gripe aviar afecta la
producción de pollo y de otros productos
avícolas la situación se produce en
medio de la elevada inflación y con las
crisis social y política que vive el
país como telón de fondo
pese a las graves cifras de
deforestación en Brasil que en febrero
llegaron a cifras récord en la amazonía
en el estado de Río de Janeiro se
desarrolla una importante iniciativa El
bosque urbano replantado más grande del
mundo
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
Estados Unidos porque los trabajadores
del Distrito Escolar unificado de la
ciudad de Los Ángeles en California
dieron inicio a tres días de protestas
para reclamar mejores condiciones
salariales los trabajadores culpan a los
sindicatos del estancamiento en las
negociaciones la suspensión de
actividades escolares amenaza con
prolongarse y afecta a más de medio
millón de estudiantes
Este martes decenas de miles de
trabajadores del Distrito Escolar
unificado de Los Ángeles iniciaron una
huelga de tres días el motivo el escaso
avance de las negociaciones paritarias
los dos gremios más importantes del
distrito se unieron para reclamar
mejores condiciones laborales y mayor
personal en el segundo sistema escolar
más grande de Estados Unidos
[Aplausos]
estos son los compañeros de trabajo que
son los trabajadores peor pagados en
nuestras escuelas y no podemos quedarnos
de brazos cruzados ya que constantemente
Los vemos irrespetados y maltratados por
este distrito
bajo la lluvia se desarrolló la primera
protesta de trabajadores y protagonizada
principalmente por maestros pero que
también incluyó ayudantes consejeros
miembros de educación especial
transportistas y conserjes entre otros
los sindicatos exigen Un aumento del 30%
y alegan que algunos trabajadores de la
comunidad educativa están por debajo de
la línea de la pobreza y luchan contra
la inflación y el alto costo de vida en
Los Ángeles
tenemos que hacerles saber que estamos
aquí por respeto y que no nos vamos a
conformar con nada menos que eso Este es
una huelga de tres días pero puede
convertirse en algo más grande si es
necesario
el sistema educativo de Los Ángeles
alberga a medio millón de estudiantes
locales y engloba la mayor parte de los
jóvenes de 25 ciudades aledañas de los
cuales tres cuartas partes son latinos
en Perú la gripe aviar está afectando la
producción de pollo y los productores
avícolas prevén que la crisis se
mantendrá Más allá del mes de abril
debido a la escasez los precios seguirán
al alza afectando los bolsillos de los
peruanos que llevan meses batallando con
la inflación avivada por factores
externos y la inestabilidad interna
veamos más
la gripe aviar obligó a los avicultores
peruanos a eliminar más de 850.000
gallinas en las últimas semanas
alrededor de 15 millones de pollos
dejaron de nacer en un mes para el
productor Avícola y representante de
avisur al exgerí las pérdidas han sido
millonarias con la cantidad que se
eliminó han perdido entre 12 y 13
millones de dólares solamente en costo
de inversión sin contar la parte que tú
la producción que la estás no la vas a
tener eso también son un ingreso que no
va a producir para afrontar la
emergencia sanitaria que ha bajado de la
producción de pollos en un 25%, el
gobierno anunció la importación de 17
millones de huevos fértiles para ser
criados en las granjas
una de las consecuencias el volumen de
pollo comercializado hoy es 7,2% menor
que el de hace un año Rosa Miranda ama
de casa Comenta que la Alimentación en
su hogar ha cambiado ya no es igual No
ya ya no Uno no puede ya dar las
porciones como dabas no y allá es menos
ya las porciones
el kilo de pollo en los mercados de Lima
y su área metropolitana promedia los
3,37 dólares 35% más caro que un año
atrás la inflación en Perú fue del 9%
anual en febrero con los alimentos
subiendo el doble impulsados por el
precio del ave
los restaurantes que venden pollo a la
brasa típica comida de los peruanos
también notan el sobrecosto y con eso
como siempre la clientela va a llover te
va a bajar porque ya el precio no es muy
accesible Y lamentablemente Tenemos que
pasar esta situación afrontarlo porque
no sabemos qué va a pasar pues porque si
se siguen
quebrar ese es el problema
los peruanos esperan que las autoridades
avancen con la vacunación de pollos y
solucionen la escasez y el alza del
precio Pero los avicultores advierten
que el proceso será lento
el gobierno ecuatoriano calificó de
atentado terrorista el envío de
dispositivos USB con explosivos a
reconocidos periodistas del país desde
el Ministerio del interior recordaron
que ya hay una investigación sobre los
cinco sobres que fueron enviados desde
la ciudad de quinzaloma uno de los
dispositivos explotó el lunes cuando el
periodista Lenin artieda del Canal
televisivo ecuavisa intentó abrirlo en
un computador del canal
el tribunal superior de justicia de
Brasil aceptó estudiar Si permite o no
el cultivo de cannabis para usos
medicinales e industriales y si facilita
los requisitos para su importación un
debate que había estado estancado en el
congreso de Brasil de tendencia
conservadora Alba Santana nos amplía
es un paso hacia la legalización de las
plantaciones de Cannabis en Brasil para
uso medicinal farmacéutico e Industrial
el tribunal superior de justicia aceptó
tomar el caso tras que los esfuerzos
para su legalización en el congreso se
estancaran en los últimos años
aceptamos delimitar la cuestión de
derecho controvertida Definir la
posibilidad de concesión de una
autorización sanitaria para la
importación y el cultivo de variedades
de cannabis para usos exclusivamente
medicinales farmacéuticos o industriales
y es que en Brasil si un paciente quiere
usar Cannabis medicinal tiene que
recurrir a productos importados más
caros que si se produjeran nacionalmente
y son varias las dolencias para las que
se suele recetar autismo Severo
epilepsia o esclerosis múltiple además
de estrés o ansiedad cuya eficacia en
estos casos ha sido reconocida por la
OMS de hecho en la región son varios los
países que ya han legalizado su uso
medicinal como Uruguay Paraguay
Argentina Colombia o Perú
tiene una relevancia práctica económica
política y social migrante por reducir
el costo de medicamentos ampliamente
utilizados por la sociedad o por la
posibilidad de introducir una nueva
industria en Brasil
de ser favorable la sentencia del
tribunal superior que se espera para el
próximo año podría convertir al
organismo judicial en pionero en la
materia como ya hizo cuando allano el
camino para legalizar el matrimonio
entre personas del mismo sexo en 2011 en
los últimos años Brasil rompió todos los
récords en cuanto a las cifras de
deforestación de sus bosques y selvas
datos oficiales revelan que la amazonía
registró en febrero de 2023 los peores
niveles de destrucción desde 2015 pero
no en todo el país es así el estado de
Río de Janeiro por ejemplo se encuentra
el bosque urbano replantado más grande
del mundo Esta es la historia
parece una Floresta casi virgen pero se
trata de un bosque reforestado
incrustado en la segunda ciudad más
poblada de Brasil
este Parque Nacional fue ideado en el
siglo XIX por el emperador Pedro II
preocupado por la falta de agua en Río
de Janeiro décadas de cultivo intensivo
del café acabaron con la mata atlántica
la vegetación original de la región y
secaron los manantiales para esta
arquitecta fue una estrategia acertada
fue extremadamente importante además La
Floresta de tijuca propicia también un
clima más ameno en la ciudad ella
suavizó el calor que hacía en Río de
Janeiro
hoy es un rincón muy apreciado por los
turistas que visitan el Cristo Redentor
erguido en la montaña del corcovado
Isabel explica que Su riqueza no es solo
medioambiental en 2012 fue declarado
patrimonio mundial y cultural por la
UNESCO
el valor cultural del parque se debe
primero al hecho de haber sido una gran
área reforestada por el hombre además
hay varios puntos hermosos en el parque
que son verdaderamente atractivos Grutas
diques capillas antiguas haciendas de
café que fueron expropiadas y
convertidas en restaurantes
El desafío ahora es preservar esta
Floresta y mejorar su hábitat la
directora cuenta que hay un programa
para reintroducir animales como macacos
a guties y Tucanes
La Floresta de tijuca hoy demuestra
cuánto un área reforestada puede
contribuir con la vida del ser humano
por ejemplo con la producción del agua
hoy una parte de la ciudad Se abastece
gracias al agua que de este bosque si no
existiese el parque de tijuca tendríamos
otra realidad en esta ciudad
estas cascadas son la prueba viva de que
es posible recuperar entornos devastados
por el hombre
fin del informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]